UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
WILL BEGIN IN THE SIXTIES IN NOW
ACTUALLY. BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY TILLAGE
COMMUNICATION WILL NOT COME TO
ORDER. A GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COPA NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. AND LEGISLATORS THE
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHER INCIDENT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC. CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WITH
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS WILL ALLOW. AND WE
WILL ALSO BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPATION TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW TODAY'S PART TO SUBMIT
NUMBER. IS. 844-291-4185 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE TWO SIX. FIVE
TWO ONE EIGHT FOR DEALS DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO LOOK AT
CONFERENCES TO WORK PLEASE REFER
TO THE SENATE AND FOR THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
BE YOU'LL WAIT I THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTE IT YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR YOU. AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND YOUR PARTICIPATION. I WILL
MAINTAIN THE CURRENT DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS. MUTED WE HAVE THREE
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA BEFORE
WE HEAR THE PRESENTATION ON THE
BILLS LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
CONSULTED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL-
WESSEL. PRESENT WESSEL PRESENCE
. HYSTER DOLLY. DOLLY HERE
BACKER. GORGEOUS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE DOT. DOT HERE
AIKMAN. EIGHT MEN HERE GONZALEZ
. GROSS. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HERE MCGUIRE. MAN MAN HERE RUBIO. RUBIO PRESENCE TURN. STERN
HERE SURE YOU HAVE A QUORUM.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM WHAT WILL
GO TO OUR FIRST BILL ITEM NUMBER
ONE OR THE BILL NUMBER SB EIGHT
THREE THREE BY SENATOR DODD THE
COMMUNITY ENERGY RESILIENCY
ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
FOLLOWING HIS PRESENTATION WILL
HAVE SPEAKERS. JOHN KENNEDY WITH
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA FOLLOWED BY KIRK
JOHNSON FROM THE CLIMATE CENTER
AND THEY DO- JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THEY'RE QUEUED UP READY TO
GO FOLLOWING HIS PRESENTATION
SENATOR DODD WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN A GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AS WELL- I
WOULD LIKE TO FIRST KNOW THAT
I'LL BE TAKING THE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS. S. B. EIGHT THREE
THREE CALLS FOR THE CREATION OF
A NEW TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GRANT
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION. TO
PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
THE RESOURCES TO DEVELOP CLEAN
ENERGY RESILIENCE PLANTS WORKING
IN COLLABORATION WITH UTILITIES
AND PRIORITIZING ENHANCE
RESILIENCE FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. THE INCREASING
FREQUENCY OF NATURAL DISASTERS
AND THE UTILITIES USE A
PROACTIVE POWER SHUT OFFS IMPOSE
ENORMOUS COSTS IN CALIFORNIA IT
PROMPTED MANY HOMEOWNERS
BUSINESSES AND UTILITIES. TO
PURCHASE HIGHLY POLLUTING BACKUP
GENERATORS. THERE IS A BETTER
ALTERNATIVE THAT ENHANCES ENERGY
RESILIENCE USING DECENTRALIZED
LOCALLY PRODUCED CLEAN ENERGY
I'M LIKE DIESEL GENERATORS THAT
MIGHT ONLY BE USED A FEW DAYS A
YEAR DISTRIBUTED CLEAN ENERGY
CAN BE USED ON A DAILY BASIS
INCLUDING TO LOAD SHIFT EXCESS
SOLAR GENERATION FROM THE MIDDLE
OF THE DAY SO THE CONCERN OF THE
EVENING. P. QUOTE. OUR STATE'S
ELECTRICAL DISTRIBUTION
UTILITIES HAVE BEEN WORKING TO
ENHANCE RESILIENCE THROUGH
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO THEM. BUT
THEY DO NOT CONTROL LOCAL PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE ROADS AND
PARKING LOTS OF MUTE MUNICIPAL
FACILITIES PLACES WHERE NEW
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES.
COULD STRATEGICALLY BE LOCATED.
BECAUSE THE ENERGY RESILIENCE IS
INHERENTLY LOCAL BUILDING A MORE
RESILIENT SYSTEM WILL REQUIRE
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH UTILITIES
THE PLAN IN SIGHT DISTRIBUTED
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES.
THIS IS WHERE S. B. EIGHT THREE
THREE FILLS THE CURRENT VOID IN
STATE POLICY. IT PROVIDES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH RESOURCES TO
DETERMINE HOW AND WHERE TO SITE
NEW ENERGY RESILIENCE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN COORDINATION
WITH THE LOCAL DISTRICT PUTIAN
UTILITY RATHER THAN HAVING
CRUCIAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT DECISIONS MEDIA
PROCESS DISCONNECTED FROM LOCAL
PRIORITIES AND NEEDS HE WOULD
FOSTER COLLABORATION. AND
STRATEGIC PLANNING. I'M JOINED
HERE TODAY BY TWO WITNESSES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT KURT JOHNSON
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY ENERGY
RESILIENCE AT THE CLIMATE
CENTER. IN JOHN KENNEDY ON
BEHALF OF THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
OKAY WE'LL GO TO WE'LL BEGIN
WITH JOHN KENNEDY MISTER KENNEDY
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTESFOR YOUR
PRESENTATION YOU CAN BEGIN NOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JOHN KENNEDY
I'M WITH RC RC AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO PROBABLY SUPPORT SB
EIGHT THIRTY THREE. ARE HERE TO
REPRESENT THIRTY NINE WORLD
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND THOSE COUNTIES HAVE BEEN HIT
HARD BY WILDFIRES AND POWER
OUTAGES OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S CONTINUED INTEREST IN
LOCAL ENERGY RESILIENCY AND HIS
WILLINGNESS TO IMPROVE THE
PROPOSAL SO I'D LIKE TO TAKE
JUST A FEW MOMENTS TO WALK YOU
THROUGH OUR WORLD AND WHY WE'RE
SO INTERESTED IN S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY THREE. AS I MENTIONED OUR
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN HIT HARD BY
PS PS AND I'M SORT OF THE LAST
FEW YEARS- THEY LEFT MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT POWER FOR
SEVERAL DAYS AT A TIME. LAST
YEAR THERE WERE OVER SIX HUNDRED
OUTAGES RELATED TO P. GENIES
DEPLOYMENT OF ITS ENHANCED POWER
LINE SAFETY SETTINGS PROGRAM
THAT PROGRAM SHUTS OFF POWER ON
TO SOMETHING COMES INTO CONTACT
WITH THEM. MOST OF THOSE OUTAGES
LASTED FOR EIGHT HOURS OR MORE
AND WE'RE EXTREMELY DISRUPTIVE
FOR RESIDENTS BUSINESSES ON THE
PROVISION OF COMMUNITY SERVICES.
WHAT YOU NEED TO EXPANSION OF
THE SETTINGS SYSTEM WIDE WE
EXPECT TO SEE EVEN MORE
DISRUPTIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT WE DON'T DISPUTE THE RISK
AVOIDANCE ROLE THAT THESE THE
PSS SYSTEMS PLAY WE JUST KNOW
THE NEED TO IMPROVE THE EXISTING
SYSTEM. TO MINIMIZE THE IMPACT
THAT STUFF OUT. FURTHERMORE IT
LAST. HAD SNOWS IN ARAPAHOE FOR
SOME WEEKS. OF OUR MORE ROOM.
NOW COMMUNITY. IT WAS THE STATE
MOVED TO ELECTRIFY THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND OTHER
THINGS. IT'S VITAL THAT WE ALSO
IMPROVE ELECTRICAL RELIABILITY
IN ALL PARTS OF THE STATE. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE A. THIRTY THREE
WILL HELP US IMPROVE ENERGY
RELIABILITY BY HELPING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BETTER UNDERSTAND
HOW TO DEVELOP SOLUTIONS. TO
MEET OUR LOCAL NEEDS. WE
APPRECIATE THAT SB EIGHT THIRTY
THREE WILL PRIORITIZE THOSE
COMMUNITIES IN GREATEST NEED AND
AT GREATEST RISK. FOR THESE
REASONS RC RC RESPECTFULLY URGES
YOUR I KNOW TODAY. THANKS VERY
MUCH WILL NOW MOVE TO. KIRK
JOHNSON FROM THE CLIMATE CENTER
YEP TWO MINUTES. VICE CHAIRMAN
DOLLY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND KIRK JOHNSON WITH
THE CLIMATE CENTER THE
ORGANIZATION SPONSORING SB EIGHT
THIRTY THREE I'M PLEASED TO
SHARE MY PERSPECTIVE ON WHY THIS
MEASURE IS SO CRITICAL. GLOBAL
TECHNOLOGY CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
HAS SOME OF THE LEAST RELIABLE
ELECTRICITY IN THE COUNTRY. AND
THE CORE OF OUR CURRENT ENERGY
RESILIENCE STRATEGY. IS DIESEL
WE CAN DO BETTER. INSTEAD
IMAGINE A DIFFERENT WORLD A
WORLD WHERE EVERY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAS FIGURED OUT HOW
TO USE CLEAN ENERGY TO SAVE
MONEY ENHANCE ENERGY RESILIENCE
FOR CRITICAL FACILITIES. LIKE LA
COUNTY SANTA BARBARA AND OTHERS
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON. A WORLD
WHERE LOCALLY DEVELOPED AND
APPROVED COMMUNITY ENERGY
RESILIENCE PLANS HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED SO THAT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDS AND STATE
CLIMATE RESILIENCE FUNDS CAN BE
QUICKLY PUT TO GOOD USE. A WORLD
WHERE CLEAN ENERGY PROVIDERS CAN
RAPIDLY PROCEED WITH PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT RATHER THAN HAVING
TO NAVIGATE LOCAL POLITICS AND
BUREAUCRACY. FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL
PROJECT. A WORLD WHERE
CALIFORNIA'S DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHICH SUFFER THE
MOST FROM AIR POLLUTION HAVE
CLEAN RELIABLE LOCAL POWER BUILT
FIRST. INSTEAD OF BEING THE LAST
TO BENEFIT FROM THE CLEAN ENERGY
REVOLUTION. A WORLD WHERE WE'RE
NOT RUNNING FOSSIL FIRED PEAKER
PLANTS EVERY EVENING TO MEET THE
EVENING PEAK LOAD. INSTEAD WE'RE
USING OUR CLEAN DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY FLEET INCLUDING MILLION
SOLAR ROOFS A MILLION ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AS LOAD SHIFTING ASSETS
STORING EXCESS SOLAR GENERATED
DURING THE DAY. SHIFTING AND
INTO THE EVENING WHEN WE NEED IT
MOST. SB EIGHT THIRTY THREE IS A
POLICY REFORM NEEDED TO HELP
MAKE THIS BETTER FUTURE
POSSIBLE. UNTIL NOW THIS KIND OF
INTENSIVE COLLABORATION BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND UTILITIES
HAS NOT BEEN NECESSARY. THE
CLIMATE CRISIS IS CHANGE THAT.
WE NEED TO ADAPT ACCORDINGLY. DO
YOU WANT TO GET SOMETHING BUILT
NEED TO HAVE A PLAN. RIGHT NOW
FOR MOST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. THE
PLAN FOR HOW TO KEEP THE LIGHTS
ON FOR CRITICAL FACILITIES IS
DIESEL. CALIFORNIA CAN DO
BETTER. I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL GO TO
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOL- THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
INSTITUTE TERM LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY SO WE ASK THAT
EVERYONE THAT CALLED IN TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. TO STATE THEIR NAME
ANY AFFILIATION AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL THAT WOULD
BE THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL SO- WE'LL GO TO
ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF SB EIGHT THIRTY THREE THERE
IS ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT NOW IS YOUR TIME TO GO
TO THE MIKE. OKAY- IF WE HAVE.
ANYONE- OKAY I THINK. I WILL GO
TO THE MODERATOR AND THE PHONE
LINES FOR SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT S.
B. EIGHT THIRTY THREE. CURRENTLY
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT THIRTY THREE IT IS THE ONE
THAT NERO. AND WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE OF THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HIMSELF UNKNOWN
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION INTO THE ATTIC THE
PORT. NEXT BAKER. HELLO TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. NEXT PICKER. WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE OF THIRTY NINE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR MARK
SPENCER MAKER ON BEHALF OF
VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
THANK YOU WITH A LOCAL LINE
TWENTY FOUR. HI INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA AGREED HE AND ARNOLD
COULD BE HAPPENED SO CALLOUSLY
FIFTY WE EARN HUGE OF THIS MUCH
NEEDED LOCAL WOODLAND PARK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER THANK
YOU. YOUR AVAILABLE TO NINE
TWENTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
ALLISON HILLIARD AND I'M WITH
REIMAGINED POWER AND THE MIGHT
TO GET A COALITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE EIGHT THIRTY
THREE THANK YOU. NEXT PICKER.
NINE THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU-
THIS IS RALPH DENNIS ON BEHALF
OF THREE FIFTY BAY AREA AND
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION ON
BEHALF OF OUR EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
VOLUNTEERS IN THE BAY AREA
REGION WE ARE AT THE CENTER TO
SUPPORT SB EIGHT THIRTY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. FINE. EIGHTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS BEN GRANDY ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF F. B. EIGHT THIRTY
THREE. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
WHAT'S THE LINE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE. HI THIS IS ERIC LEON
CHAIRMAN. SERVICE AND SPECIAL
CLIMATE COALITION- SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB. EIGHT
THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. REPORTER LINE NUMBER
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CAROL LEAD REPRESENTING THE
DEMOCRATS ABROAD AND ALONG THE
CREEK IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT SPEAKER.
PHOTO LINE NUMBER FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS GOPAL
SHANKAR FROM RECYCLED ENERGY AND
REGENERATION NAPA COUNTY IN NAPA
COUNTY- IN STRONG SUPPORT TO BE
THIRTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. REPORTER LINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ROGER DICKINSON ON
BEHALF OF CIVIC WELL FORMERLY
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. GREETINGS
TO MY GOOD FRIEND ROGER- NEXT
SPEAKER PLEASE. WHAT ABOUT THE
LINE NUMBER THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
SHERRY LEAR WITH THREE FIFTY
SOUTH LOS ANGELES AND THREE
FIFTY SOUTH PLAN LEGISLATIVE
ALLIANCE. THE STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK- THE BOTTOM
LINE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AARON
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WEEK- MEXICO IS ABOUT
TO LINE NUMBER SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI CYNTHIA SHALLOTTE ON
WITH INDIVISIBLE GREEN TEAM IN
SACRAMENTO INDIVISIBLE AND I'M
IN FRONT OF THE COURT OF F. B.
EIGHT THIRTY THREE TO HELP
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY IN OUR- OUR
COMMUNITY TO BE SELF RELIANT
RESILIENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. ONCE AGAIN IT IS A
REMINDER IF YOU ARE INTO PORT AT
EIGHT THIRTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'LL GET IN THE
QUEUE. AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY IN CUBA FOR CARE OKAY
RIGHT WELL YOU HAVE A COUPLE OF.
HEARING UP AND VERY. IT CAME UP
A LITTLE LATE HERE. IT'LL BE
JUST ONE SECOND OKAY WE'LL WAIT. WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF THE
FORTY YEAR OLD ACTOR OKAY WHAT
WHAT A LINE OF FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS BRUCE
SAUNDERS AND I'M WITH
INDIVISIBLE ROCK VALLEY AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT. STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THAT THREE EIGHT
THREE THREE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ANY OTHER SPEAKERS. WE DO
HAVE ONE MORNING I HAVE MY
NUMBER FORTY TWO. HELLO MY NAME
IS LESLIE OFTEN I'M WITH LET
GREEN CALIFORNIA I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL EIGHT
THIRTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON AND WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY YOU. WILL
MAKE A MOVE ON TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE AN
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION SCHEDULED
WILL GO DIRECTLY TO ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION TO WE HAVE ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY. WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP
EIGHT THIRTY THREE. ANYONE OKAY
WILL GO DIRECTLY TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR- IF YOU COULD
KILL ANYONE ON THE LINES THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT THIRTY
THREE. ONLY IF YOU ARE IN THE
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT THIRTY
THREE IT WOULD BE ONE BEEN THERE
ON YOUR PHONE. THE ONE THEN ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYBODY QUEUED UP MCPHERSON
OKAY VERY WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MEMBERS DOES
ANYONE WISH TO EITHER SPEAK
COMMENT ASK QUESTIONS REMOVE THE
BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION BY-
SENATOR AIKMAN. AND THE BILL
THERE IS- A DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS MOTION- CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. S. B.
EIGHT THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR
DODD DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL BY WESSEL
HI DOLLY. DOLLY I BECKER.
GORGEOUS BRADFORD BRADFORD I DON
. DIED HI IGMAN. EIGHT MEN HI
GONZALEZ. HELLO. GROVE HI
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI MCGUIRE.
MAN MAN BY RUBIO. RUBIO BY STERN. SURE THERE'S NINE ETS OKAY
WE'LL HAVE WE'LL KEEP THE ROAD
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS WILL
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B.
EIGHT THIRTY NINE. BY THE VERY
VERY HARD WORKING IN US SENATOR
DODD. ANOTHER ENERGY BILL THIS
YANKEE MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS SP EIGHT THIRTY NINE
CODIFIES IT STANDARDIZES THE
RULES FOR THE BASE INTERRUPTIBLE
PROGRAM KNOWN AS- I ACCEPT THIS
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS NOTED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. I THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR HER HELP
. THE BISHOP IS AN EMERGENCY
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAM IT HELPS
CONTRIBUTE TO GRID RELIABILITY
WIND GENERATION CAPACITY BECOME
SCARCE OR DURING TRANSMISSION
EVENTS WHICH LIMIT ACCESS TO
SUPPLY. I'M SURE EVERYONE ON
THIS COMMITTEE REMEMBERS THE
SUMMER BLACKOUTS FROM TWENTY
TWENTY. ON AUGUST FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA CALLED
ON THE RELIABILITY WE RIGHT
EXCUSE ME RELIABILITY DEMAND
RESPONSE WHICH IS MOSTLY THE
BILL UP FOR A TOTAL OF FIVE
CONSECUTIVE DAYS TO HELP MANAGE
THE EXTREME HEAT AND ELECTRIC.
ELECTRICITY USAGE AT LEAST SEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO MEGAWATTS OF
LOAD WAS SHED MOST OF THAT BY
THE INDUSTRIAL CUSTOMERS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE BACKUP.
WITHOUT THE BACKUP THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR WOULD HAVE BEEN FORCED
TO CALL MORE ROTATING OUTAGES
WHICH ILLUSTRATED NEARLY EIGHT
MILLION CALIFORNIANS AN HOUR TO
FEND WITHOUT ELECTRICAL POWER.
THE BIT WAS CALLED AGAIN IN THE
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY OVER
THE LABOR DAY WEEKEND FIRST MUCH
AS THREE CONSECUTIVE DAYS AGAIN
PREVENTING ROLLING BLACKOUTS
FROM ENDANGERING- CALIFORNIA
STORY ANOTHER EXTENDED HEAT
STORM. EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS
GREAT IMBALANCES AND OTHER
CHALLENGES WILL CONTINUE
CALIFORNIA NEEDS CLEANING
EMERGENCY RELIABILITY RESOURCES
THERE'S NOTHING CLEANER THAN
AVOIDING CONSUMPTION TO BEGIN
WITH. BY CODIFYING BIT WE
ENSURED THAT THE C. P. U. C. THE
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR IN
THE ENERGY COMMISSION WILL
INCLUDE THE EMERGENCY DEMAND
RESPONSE THEIR PLANS TO AVOID
ENERGY SUPPLY SHORTFALLS. SP
EIGHT THIRTY NINE IS SPONSORED
BY THE CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION WHOSE
MEMBERS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
SHEDDING LOAD DURING GREAT
EMERGENCIES LIKE THE SUMMER OF
TWENTY TWENTY. I HAVE ADDED
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
THAT THE AGRICULTURE COULD
CUSTOMERS- ARE INCLUDED AS BIT
PARTICIPANTS AS THEY ALWAYS HAVE
BEEN. FINALLY GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS HAVE BEEN TAKING
PLACE AMONGST THE OPPOSITION IN
MY TEAM AND I ARE COMMITTED TO
KEEP ON WORKING WITH THEM MOVING
FORWARD I BELIEVE NOR SHOULD WE
FROM CLICK A IS ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
OKAY WILL MAKE SURE OF THAT- NOR
SURE REEF- CALIFORNIA LARGE.
ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION
HAVE FOUR MINUTES FOR YOUR
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION FOR YOU
ON THE LINE. YES I AM THANK YOU
SHOULD I BEGIN YES PLEASE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SHARE WITH THEM
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU AS
WELL TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS NARESH
ERA. AND I'M TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF QUICKER TO SUPPORT AT
THE EIGHT THIRTY NINE. THE BASE
INTRACTABLE PROGRAM HAS SAVED
CALIFORNIANS FROM ROLLING
BLACKOUTS FOR DECADES. ADDING
VALUABLE CLEAN RELIABILITY LOAD
SHED IN TIME GREAT STRESS. OVER
THE PAST TWO YEARS THAT SENATOR
DODD NOTED IT HAD BEEN CALLED
NINE TIMES EIGHT TIMES IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND ONE THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IT CAN AND HAS BEEN
CALLED SYSTEM WIDE OR ON A MORE
GRANULAR BASIS IF THERE'S A
LOCAL RELIABILITY NEEDS IN A
LOCAL AREA. FIFTY PROGRAMS ALSO
SERVE ANOTHER COURT DATE POLICY
GOAL PREVENTING ECONOMIC AND
EMISSIONS LEAKAGE BY PROVIDING
PARTICIPATING INDUSTRIAL
CUSTOMERS WITH A MUCH NEEDED
TOOL TO HELP MITIGATE THE
IMPACT. OF THE VERY HIGH COST OF
ELECTRICITY IN CALIFORNIA. F. B.
EIGHT THIRTY NINE IS A
STREAMLINED VERSION OF THE BILL
THAT WAS VOTED OUT UNANIMOUSLY
LAST YEAR BY THE COMMITTEE. IT
ENSURES THAT THE CPC RETAINS
DISCRETION OVER THIS IMPORTANT
PROGRAM FROM THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS EVALUATION WHICH
OCCUR REGULARLY TO SETTING THE
INCENTIVE LEVELS TO OTHER
PROGRAM PARAMETERS. WE HAVE HAD
MORE TIME TO WORK WITH
INTERESTED PARTIES THAT ENGAGED
WITH THAT AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ADDRESS ALL OF THE CONCERNS
PROVIDED TO US DIRECTLY. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING THIS A
CONSENSUS BILL BECAUSE IT MAKES
SUCH AN IMPORTANT NEED
RELIABILITY. SEVEN CALIFORNIA
EDISON HAD SENT HIM A LETTER
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND PG&E
HAS TOLD CREEK- THAT THEY ALSO
SUPPORT THE BILL. WE ARE
CONTINUING TO HAVE INFORMAL
CONVERSATION WITH C. P. C. R. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL. I THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR IPHONE.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW WILL GO TO
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IF ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY.
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT THIRTY NINE. NOW IS
YOUR TIME TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. I DON'T SEE ANYONE.
I WILL GO TO THE MODERATOR WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES. MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT THIRTY NINE. IF YOU ARE
AN APARTMENT AT EIGHT THIRTY
NINE YOU NEED TO PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. THE OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PUT YOU BACK IN Q. ONCE AGAIN IT
IS ONE NINE ZERO. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON KIDNEY SAND ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA E. THEY SHOULD
BE AND MAN MANAGEMENT COUNCIL IF
THE COURT AT EIGHT THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER
. REVOKED LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ALLOW THAT BOTTOM
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
MONTHLY THING OFFERING THE
MONSTERS FOR WORKING WITH THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- AND THE
NEXT BILL. ACTUALLY THE BOTTOM
LINE NUMBER THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
ROB SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
VERY WELL NEXT PICKER. IF WE
HAVE ANY IN SUPPORT OF AT EIGHT
THIRTY NINETY TO ONE THEN ZERO.
NOT HAD ANYBODY QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR OKAY WE'LL MOVE TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
NON. REGISTERED FOR AN ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION IF THERE'S ANY
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT THIRTY NINE HERE IN THE
GALLERY. MANY SPEAKERS HELLO WE
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION WILL GO TO
THE MODERATOR FOR ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT THIRTY
NINE. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF
ACT II EIGHT THIRTY NINE OF ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. I JUST
WONDER YOU GERALD FOR
APPLICATION S. T. E. THIRTY NINE
. B. ONE SECOND.
APPLICATION OF X. P. EIGHT
THIRTY NINE JUST WONDERING HERO. WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY KILLING
UP RESEARCHER. OKAY VERY WELL
WILL COME TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IF THERE'S ANYONE THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK-
CENTER DOLLY. MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS CONCERNS COMMENTS NOT
AT ALL WE HAVE. AGAIN ONTO THE
AUTHOR I JUST TO SPEAK TO THE
AMENDMENTS JUST WANNA CLARIFY.
AUTHORS GOOD WITH YOU MAN YES
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. IF WE
COULD HAVE THE CLICK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. S. B. EIGHT THIRTY
NINE BY SENATOR DODD DO YOU PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WESSEL. BY WESSEL HI DOLLY.
DOLLY HI BECKER. GORGEOUS
BRADFORD. BRADFORD BY. DOT DONNA
HI IGMAN. EIGHT MEN HI GONZALEZ
. GROSS HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I
REQUIRE. MAN MAN HI RUBIO. RUBIO
HI STERN. SURE THERE'S EIGHTY
EIGHTH OKAY WE'LL KEEP THE-
BRELO CONTRAPTION MEMBERS NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE BEST BILL
THAT OF THE DAY WILL BE CHAIRED
BY THE- BEST ENERGY VICE CHAIR
OF THE LEGISLATURE. YOU WANT TO
COOK- FROM THE DESK OKAY. JUST
YOU CAN YOU WERE PRESENT FROM
THEIR. WHATEVER YOU SAY MR
BLACKMUN THE LATEST PRESENT SP
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN WAY SO GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON BY CHURCH MEMBERS- I'D
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS S. B. EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN IS A SIMPLE SUNSET
EXTENSION BILL. TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS CAN CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO
BASIC TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES. THIS BILL EXTENDS
EXTENDS THE OPERATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH COST FUNDS BY
FIVE YEARS UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS EXTENDED THE
OPERATION OF THESE HIGH COST
FUND. EIGHT TIMES SINCE THEIR
CREATION THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
COURT COSTS FUNDS PROVIDE RATE
ASSISTANCE THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
THAT MUST PROVIDE BASIC
TELEPHONE PHONE SERVICES. IN
AREAS OF THE STATE WHERE THE
COST OF PROVIDING SERVICES ARE
YOU ON USUALLY HIGH. MANY OF
THESE HIGH COST OR RULE
COMMUNITIES- WITH- HI HI
WILDFIRE RISKS AND HIGHER
INFRASTRUCTURE COST. IS B. FIVE
SEVEN SUPPORTS CALIFORNIA'S
UNIVERSAL TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICE POLICY BY ENABLING THE
STATE TO MAXIMIZE FEDERAL
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR HIGH
COST TELECOMMUNICATIONS SUPPORT.
AND ENSURING THE CALIFORNIANS
AND HIGH COST COMMUNITIES
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO NINE
ONE ONE. AN ESSENTIAL
TELECOMMUNICATION SERVICES. AS
PAID FIVE SEVEN HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
SENATOR NOW WE'LL GO TO OUR LEAD
WITNESS SAID CHARLIE BORN AND
THEN OUR SECOND LEAD WILL
WITNESS PAM LOOMIS MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE T. UP OUR
FIRST- LEAD WITNESS. AIRLINES
ARE OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE NATURALLY
BORN DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
ENSURING ALL CHARACTER PRINTER.
WE ARE A LARGE- LOCAL EXCHANGE
CARRIERS SERVING IN MANY AREAS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA FROM NORTH
OF SAN DIEGO TO THE OREGON
BORDER. AND THEN FROM COACH TOO
THE NEVADA AND ARIZONA BORDERS
AS WELL. SO WE INCLUDE MANY OF
THE HIGH COST- RURAL AREA. IN
RETURN WE OFFER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD TO EXTEND THE
FRONT END OF THE FARM. PROGRAM
FOR AN ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS.
THE PROGRAMS ARE ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY M. PUBLIX'S. FIRST
PORTABILITY. THE PROGRAM TO
GUARANTEE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
NO MATTER WHERE THEY LIVE HAVE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE DISTRICT
BOYS SERVERS AND THE ABILITY TO
CALL NINE ONE ONE. THE TRANSPORT
IS PROVIDED PICTURES OF LAST
RESORT ONLY FOR THE HIGH COST OF
PARKS WHERE THE COSTS OF
PROVIDING SERVERS. IT IS ABOUT
THIRTY SIX DOLLARS PER MAPPED
OUT WAS DETERMINED IN A LENGTHY.
LOOSELY PROTECTED AND- PRINTERS
MONTHLY SERVICE FOR THE-
AVERAGES TWENTY TWO DOLLARS
WITHOUT THE FRONT SUPPORT THE
ROAD TO RECOVER THE COSTS OF
PROVIDING SERVICE IN RURAL
REMOTE AREAS WOULD BE MUCH
HIGHER THAN THAT AMOUNT AND IN
SOME AREAS BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED
AND TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
IT WOULD NOT BE AFFORDABLE. SO
THE GOOD BARN DOES PLAY A
CRUCIAL AND FOUNDATIONAL-
INSURING THE COMMUNICATION
NETWORK CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE DISTRICT SERVERS. TO
ALL CUSTOMERS AND IT'S UNFAIR
AND COMPETITIVELY NEUTRAL WAY TO
SPREAD THESE COSTS. THROUGHOUT
THE CUSTOMER BILL. THE REGARDING
PUBLIC SAFETY ANNOUNCEMENT
MENTIONED- IF YOU WERE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE HIGH COST AREA ON A
MAP VIRTUES. WHAT A PLEASE SEE A
DOCTOR THE FIRE MAP DESIGNATED
AND- HI- FIRE DANGER ISN'T HERE
TO ENSURE CURRENT. CLEAR A
PRETTY GOOD OVERLOAD AND THEN
YOU CAN AREAS- INCREASING COSTS
OVER THE YEARS. ESPECIALLY. WITH
ADDITIONAL- THIRTY MEASURES IN
POLAND STRUCTURE AND SO FORTH.
THE DELIVERY CHARGES AFFORDABLE
ACCESS TO SERVERS CAPABLE OF
DOWNING NINE ONE ONE IN THE
EVENT OF A FIRE OR OTHER
EMERGENCY. MOREOVER THE WIRELINE
VOICE SERVER IS ONLY. SERVICE
AVAILABLE TO MANY OF THE HIGH
FIRE DANGER AREA. INSPECTION IF
THEY DON'T HAVE- BROADBAND OR
WIRELESS. SO FINALLY I WANT TO
KNOW THE B. TOWN CURRENTLY HAS A
0% SURCHARGE ON PHONE BILLS.
WHICH WILL CONTINUE DURING THE
FIVE YEAR EXTENSION THROUGH THE
BILL. ALL FORMS WILL CONTINUE TO
REFLECT THE BENEFITS OF THE
PROGRAM WITHOUT HAVING TO PAY
THE ADDITIONAL. FEES ON THEIR
PHONE BILL THERE IS A FAIRLY
HEALTHY BALANCING THE FINE. AND
IS MORE THAN ENOUGH TO COVER THE
FIVE YEAR. THANK YOU AGAIN WE
THANK THE AUTHOR AND CO AUTHOR
URGENT SUPPORT THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE TO OUR SECOND LEAD
SUPPORT PAM LOOMIS. PLEASE MAKE
YOUR COMMENTS BRING IT. A LITTLE
BIT WHO WILL DO GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT AGAIN
MY NAME IS PAMELA MANSON ON THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S INDEPENDENT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
WHICH ARE TEN MILE COMPANY
SERVING RURAL AREAS THE
CALIFORNIA THAT LACK ECONOMIES
OF SCALE- WE EXTEND OUR
GRATITUDE TO PLANET EARTH QUAKE
SO FOR CARRYING THIS IMPORTANT
BILL AND THE EIGHT HUNDRED
PARTICULAR ENABLED SMALL WORLD
TELEPHONE COMPANIES.
INCREMENTALLY AND RESPONSIBLY
UPGRADE THEIR NETWORKS WITH
FUTURE PROOF TECHNOLOGY WHILE
KEEPING TELEPHONE RATES
AFFORDABLE- WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. UNDER THIRTY EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN. ALL THANK YOU SO NOW WE
WILL GO TO- THOSE WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS. I DO NOT SEE ANYONE
NOW WE CAN GO TO THE MODERATOR
OF MODERATE WOULD YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN. YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
ACT B. EIGHT FIVE SEVEN IS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND WE
WILL GO TO THE FIRST LINE FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. KAREN
MEMBERS ONLY SHIP PRIEGO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION HOW
CALM AND WE ARE CLOSED OUT THERE
ON THE MEASURE AN INTERIM
SUPPORT INNER DRIVE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE OF TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS TREATED RIGHT WITH THE
WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTED
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. REPORTER THE NEXT LINE OF
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS PETE HERNANDEZ WITH AT AND T.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN LIKE TO TAKE THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
EIGHT WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN
Q. MESSENGER. THANK YOU WE DID
NOT HAVE LEAD OPPOSITION BUT I
WOULD LIKE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
Q. AND I SEE HELLO. WE HAVE
SOMEBODY IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS
ARE YOU- IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN OKAY YOU CAN SPEAK.
YOU SAID GO AHEAD YES GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS STEVEN CALIF I'VE
SERVED. ON THE P. C. C. H. E. F.
A. A MINISTRY OF COMMITTEE FOR
THE PAST DOZEN YEARS. INCLUDING
SEVERAL YEARS AS CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY MY COMMENTS
TODAY ARE MY OWN. I'M HERE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED THE LAW
NEEDS TO BE AMENDED TO ACCOUNT
FOR RECENT DECISIONS OF PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION FOLLOWING
TENURE LONG YEARS OF HEARINGS IN
R. ONE ONE ONE ONE OH OH SEVEN.
R. ONE ONE ONE ONE OH SEVEN EXAM
THE GREAT DETAIL THE DYNAMICS OF
THE A- FUND AND DETERMINE THE
SUPPORT FROM THE FUND. HAS BEEN
AND CONTINUES TO BE EXCESSIVE.
I'VE WATCHED COMMISSION STAFF
TRY TO DO RIGHT BY THE REPAIRS
OF CALIFORNIA AGAINST A SCORCHED
EARTH LEGAL STRATEGY BY THE
SMALL LEGACY PHONE COMPANIES.
FOLLOWING AMENDMENT OF THE
ENABLING LEGISLATION IN TWENTY
ELEVEN- THE PHONE COMPANIES WITH
SUPPORT FROM THE FANS HAVE BEEN
BUILDING OUT A NEW PLATFORM
FIBER OPTICS TO REPLACE COPPER.
AND ARRIVING INTENTIONAL
REVENUES INCOME FROM THIS. NEW
INFORMATION NETWORK WITHOUT ANY
REDUCTION IN SUPPORT FROM
CALIFORNIA RATEPAYERS. THE
COMMISSION IS MOVING FORWARD TO
REDUCE EXCESS OF A PLANNED
SUPPORT. BASED ON REASONABLE
INTERPRETATION OF LAW. THE PHONE
COMPANIES ARE CHALLENGING THE
DECISIONS IN COURT. THE TIME HAS
COME FOR A MORE EXPLICIT
STATEMENT OF LEGISLATIVE INTENT
TO REIN IN EXCESSIVE SUPPORT
FROM THE A FUND. I SUGGEST IN
PARAGRAPH B. SUBPARAGRAPH THREE
ADDING THE PHRASE INCLUDING
AFFILIATES NET BROADBAND INCOME
AND QUOTE. AFTER THE PHRASE
OTHER SOURCES OF INCOME. AND
PARAGRAPH C. SUBPARAGRAPH FOR.
ADDING THE PHRASE QUOTE AN
AFFILIATED INTERNET BROADBAND
PROVIDERS AND QUOTE AFTER QUOTE
CUSTOMERS OF EACH INDEPENDENT.
TELEPHONE CORPORATION. AGAIN THE
P. U. C. HAS REACHED A DECISION
IN THIS MATTER AFTER TEN YEARS
THEY'VE DETERMINED AS A MATTER
OF FACT THE THIRTY OF FUNDING.
SUPPORT IS EXCESSIVE AND IT
WOULD BEHOOVE. THE LEGISLATURE
TO. MODIFY SLIGHTLY IN THE
LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL TWO OF THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT AND PUT THEM INTO
CONSISTENCY WITH THE PC THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE- SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE. WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN. IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB EIGHT FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT
OF ONE MAN THERE ON YOUR PHONE.
CANADA'S APPOSITION. NINE ZERO.
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
QUEUING UP THE SUBJECT THANK YOU
WE'D LIKE TO BRING IT NOW BACK
TO THE LEGISLATORS IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE LEGISLATORS
I WOULD ASK THAT YOU. SEEING I
HAVE A MOTION WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. HER WAIST. THANK YOU AND
I APPRECIATE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL AND- WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
FOLLOW UP IN THE COMMENTS MADE
BY THE GERMAN OPPOSITION I
WASN'T AWARE OF THAT MATTER
WE'RE GONNA LOOK INTO IT. THE
SEE IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN DO ABOUT THAT SO- APPRECIATE
AND I VOTE ON THIS BILL. TO MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU THAT IS DUE
TO PASS TO. AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. S. B. EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN BY SENATOR WESSEL THE
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL FIVE
WESSEL HI DOLLY HI DOLLY HI
BECKER. PORGES BRADFORD BRADFORD
I DON. DOT HI IGMAN. EIGHT MEN
HI GONZALEZ. GROVE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG I REQUIRE. MAN MAN HI
RUBIO. RUBIO HI STERN OKAY. SURE
THAT THE EIGHTIES. OKAY SO- WILL
HOLD THE ROLE PERHAPS MEMBERS OF
WE'RE GONNA- NOW CALLED ON THE
ABSENT MEMBERS TO- COME BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO- THEIR VOTES IF
THEY WISH. OF. FOR ALL THE
MEMBERS WHO VOTED ON ALL THREE
BILLS WITH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION.
DO YOU HAVE ANY.
OKAY WE HAVE THREE MEMBERS HERE-
WE'LL TAKE UP ITEM FILE LINE
NUMBER ONE SP THIRTY THREE BY
SENATOR DODD CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE UPSET MEMBERS. THREE EIGHT
THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR DODD TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BECKER. BECKER HI
FORGES GONZALEZ INSTALLERS HI MY
CHOIR. STERN STERN I. OKAY WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO SP
FIVE EIGHT THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR DODD- CLICK PLEASE CALL
THE OPTION MEMBERS SP EIGHT
THREE NINE BY SENATOR DODD DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. BECKER BECKER I
PORCHES. GONZALEZ IS ALL THIS
HIGH GROWTH. STERN. STERN I
REQUIRE. OKAY. THANK YOU KEEP
THE BILL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
ON WE'LL GO TO ITEM THREE SP
EIGHT FIVE SEVEN BY CENTER
WESSEL CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
OPTION MEMBERS SP EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN BY SENATOR WESSEL DU PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BECKER BAKER HI OR JUST.
GONZALEZ IS ALL THIS HIGH GROWTH
. MCGUIRE STERN. STERN I. HE
WILL KEEP THE BILL- THE REAL
OPEN FOR OPTION MEMBERS WERE
STILL WAITING ON ONE MEMBER.
THERE HE IS OKAY- CLERK LET'S
TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER ONE AGAIN.
PLEASE CALL THE OPPOSITE
MEMBERS. SP EIGHT THREE THREE BY
SENATOR DODD DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS FORTUS.
REQUIRE REQUIRE HI THIRTEEN A
STIR- ITEM NUMBER TWO PLEASE FOR
THE UPS MEMBERS SP EIGHT THREE
NINE BY SENATOR DODD DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BURGESS GROVE. MCGUIRE REQUIRE
HI TWELVE A STIR THANK YOU I
WILL GO TO I REMEMBER THREE FOR
ALL THE UPS MEMBERS SP EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN BY SENATOR WESSEL DU
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS GORGEOUS. GROSS
MCGUIRE REQUIRE HI TWELVE A STIR
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL
CLOSE THE ROLE. ON ALL THE BILLS
NOW THE- I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THE SENATE. ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO THIS PROCESS AND WE
WANT INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN
PARTICIPATION WITH WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS IS NOW
ADJOURNED.